hello everyone and welcome to today's
keynote presentation realizing
point-of-care instrumentation one
institutions experience presented by dr.
death Sewell eylem director legal
chemistry and point-of-care testing and
in Robert H lurie Children's Hospital of
Chicago
I am Alexis Krause of laberd's and I
will be our moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots laborat is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars before I begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on ask a question box located on the far
left to your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appears on the screen our speaker will
respond to your questions via email if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please that click on the
ask a question box to let us know that
you're having a problem this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Sewell eylem I will now turn the
presentation over to her
thank you very much Alexis and thanks to
lab roots for this invitation to share
my work on standardizing point-of-care
instrumentation as my learning
objectives for today at the completion
of this session you would be able to
describe the process of standardizing
point-of-care instrumentation based on
our experience and be able to list those
challenges associated with standardizing
point-of-care instrumentation and also
the hope is that you'll be able to
discuss the advantages of standardizing
point-of-care instrumentation I do not
have any
financial disclosures pertaining to this
presentation what our care testing goes
a long way to help health care
institutions provide fast and reliable
testing right near the patient by doing
this when care testing allows for rapid
clinical decision making which helps a
lot with patient with care delivery
money care testing instrumentations are
portable as such allowing for them to be
able to take to be taken wherever it's
needed for example in the out in the
mission field or in a remote location
and so it really has gone a long way to
increase global access to care and also
because infrastructure costly
infrastructure is not really needed for
chronic care testing instrumentation
this is really me this really makes
funny care testing affordable and so
allows for areas for resource low areas
or areas that are not don't really have
a lot of resources to be able to afford
point of care testing I suppose to our
with gigantic lab instrumentation that
cost a fortune
and so with this in mind you can see
just how advantageous point-of-care
testing is and because of these
advantages of Quanah care testing it is
pretty common or it's pretty common in a
lot of across different clinical
departments and so even though and so
because of this the fact that it's
widely available different types of
instrumentation for the same task you
would frequently find that in the same
institution they're gonna have multiple
different tasks for multiple different
instrumentation for the same task and so
knowing this and so knowing that you
could go out and acquire
any type of instrumentation that you
want and sometimes you would this would
be because of provider because of
provider preferences where maybe they
came from an institution where specific
type of instrumentation was used and so
they want that specific one or maybe
just a historical effect for that
institution whereby you know different
departments go out and acquire their own
instrumentation you can actually have
all these different types of devices for
the the same tasks in the within the
same instrumentation so with with this
being said the question I would ask you
today is in your institution do you have
different device types for the same test
so because I can because the system does
not have a pulling pulling ability for
me to see your answers I'm going to
share my experience from at least the
recent AACC American Association for
clinical chemistry conference in Chicago
we're at the point of care coordinators
forum I asked this question in a crowd
of about 200 participants and about an
over 80% of the participants actually
said that yes in their institutions they
have multiple different advice tags for
the exact same task and only about 13%
of of participants that that know they
do not have this they actually have this
under control so that's great right it's
only a very small percentage of
institutions that don't have this
problem so my institution was no
exemption it was not exempt to this
point of care device creep right so at
one point in our session we did have
four blood gas analysis not just one but
not two not three but four different
types of point of care instrumentations
for blood gas analysis one hand held
which meant that you could take it
anywhere for testing right there to
fishness bedside and he had three
different bench tops
but gas analyzers but these were all
maintained on a certain on the same
floor in a blood gas in a blood gas loud
per se and you would have respiratory
therapists performing the testing or
perfusionist if it was incredible scare
surgery and you would have people
actually go get the samples and come
perform the testing before getting the
results back so this is what was
happening for our blood gas analysis
setup meanwhile for a CT testing which
is another scenario we had one to three
different types of blood gas of sorry of
point care instrumentation for a CT
testing from three different vendors in
our institution and so looking at the
fact that we had all these multiple
device types for the same tests the
issue it presents a lot of different
challenges for the institution and for
example for my institution in looking at
this this could confound the
interpretation of the status of the
patient right decisions are being made
based on the results from these
different tests or these different
Institute from these different
instrument types and so for example if
you have multiple different a CT devices
for different areas of the hospital and
you have the same provider who's
providing care in those different areas
or you have a patient moving from the o
R to the floor so are moving between
departments using different a CT devices
could actually confound the
interpretation of the anticoagulation
status of the patient especially when
something with a test like a CT where
this test is this testing is not
standardized and so you're actually
getting different results from different
instrument types and looking at
hemoglobin for example having multiple
different instrumentation and a patient
being tested in one area of the hospital
with a different instrument type in them
moving to another area and being tested
with another instrument type this could
actually
found the interpretation for the need
for transfusion for a patient and so
this actually said was a big concern to
us the other challenge that having lots
of device types opposes is that of
decreased efficiency of operators and
even of our Ponty care staff having a
variety of processes based on the
different instrument types so if there's
a wide variability in the processes are
involved in operating these different
instruments different tabs multiple
stacks are an instrument and not as many
for other instrument types different
workflows in different areas based on
the type fishman they have this is
actually with this variability and
considering that in most healthcare
issues you have a resource personnel who
are floating between floors of between
clinical areas but actually the cause
will give this learning curve that every
time a resource opera resource employee
who's been working one area for a while
and then goes to another era and now has
to remember how to use that instrument
time but because of this learning curve
that could actually increase the number
of p analytic error say you would have
it decreases compliance sometimes it
unreal they don't remember where did you
have to run quality control and so it
causes a lot of compliance issues and
also with your point of care staff
having to the point of case having to
maintain inventory for all these
different device types which are present
in different parts of the hospital
having to do calibration verification
for different instrument types forming
instrumentation compares so there's a
lot of things that we could talk about
here that when a care staff have to do
so that just things that they wouldn't
have to do they just had one type of
punic instrumentation so that would
greatly decrease the efficiency as well
and so another area
makes it challenges the fact that this
actually increases cost right for
example if you have multiple different
types you have to pay maintenance fees
yearly maintenance fees with these
different instrument types which
increases the cost versus only paying it
for one instrument type you have to the
the cost for your consumables goes up
because you have lower volumes of tests
lower test volumes distributed across
the banishment ties meanwhile if you
have one instrument type then you have a
higher volume and so that costs usually
vendors who give you better pricing for
larger volumes testing test volumes so
this definitely being able to having
multiple different types would certainly
increase your cost and so knowing what
these challenges are can you see how
advantageous it would be to standardize
from multiple different types to
hopefully a single instrument tied for a
specific Essene point-of-care test for
example for blood gas analysis or a CT
testing the example that we use here
certainly you would be able to see you
would enjoy that teaches in three main
areas the size divided here you could
you see improved efficiency would you
staff the operators they would have
reduced learning curves because it
doesn't matter what part of the hospital
they're working in they would have to
deal with this through the same
instrument time and so they don't have
to try to figure out or remember how to
operate the instrument you would all
that would also go to improve your
quality because they're narrow improve
compliance it would decrease your pre
analytic errors because they're doing a
similar thing each time it doesn't
matter what part of the hospital they
are working in they would be using the
same they will be using the same
instrument type and so this would
decrease variability basically
the other thing is this also will
decrease costs right once you improve
efficiency of your personnel it goes
without saying that that would increase
the cost because that frees up your
personnel from doing a lot of things
that don't add value to patient care but
would rather make their workflows more
efficient to improve patient flow as
well which again goes there goes a long
way to improve revenue for the
institution it would decrease your
consumable expenses and that you have
higher volumes so you can get better
pricing from manufacturers also and also
it goes without saying it will decrease
your maintenance fees because now you
don't have to pay maintenance fees for
multiple device types or to multiple
vendors but you cannot just do that to a
single or if you were veterus basically
and so with all of these advantages to
standardizing point-of-care test saying
you know if I were to ask all of you
today should we standardize our Medicare
instrumentation do you want to
standardize of course if you're gonna
get all those advantages you probably
should standardize it so but is it as
easy as weird is it just as easy as
saying it standardizing you go out and
standardize your multiple
instrumentation of course not there's so
much Allen jizz that you would have to
overcome one of them is change
management right with change not
everybody wants change people have been
used to using the same type of testing
for many years maybe they've worked
there for several years so they're used
to the status quo and now you're trying
to change from bringing new new
instrument types this or for their area
if you're gonna standardize this
certainly would require a lot of
training than to learn new things so you
have to have a plan as to how to manage
the change I also did a collection right
so you would have to be able to convince
people that you need this changes so
collecting that data might not be as
easy especially if your instrumentation
or not an interface so as was the case
in my institution and so all of that
data is not readily available and also
the cost of acquiring the new
instrumentation so if you do decide to
standardize to one type of
instrumentation that means that that
specific type of instrumentation will
have to be purchased and made available
institution-wide and so that there's a
cost associated with that which would
probably be a significant cost to begin
with and so these are all challenges
that you would have to face so taking a
look at just focusing a little bit in on
change management which is the biggest
challenge in my opinion that I think you
would probably encounter or that we
encountered with standardizing is being
able to choose an instrument time that
would meet the needs of every clinical
area that uses that that has need for
that test and so getting everyone to
agree on one specific instrument
especially if it's not the instrument
type that they're currently using in the
our area it's gonna be challenging so
you would definitely have to come up
with some sort of strategy as to how to
get an instrument type that will meet
all of their needs but also involve them
in the process so that you could get a
wider acceptance of the change and the
other thing is you would have to come up
with a plan as to training right so your
personnel will have to learn the new
instrument types so this is a challenge
because now you have to do more of an
institution-wide training so it's not
just you training a few pests nuts you
training a lot of people so for all
hundreds if you have a big institution
if you're in a bigger institution like
mine where we have to train hundreds of
people you have to come up with the plan
for that so that would be a challenge
and getting people maybe who've worked
there for years to learn
different types a new type of
instrumentation will be a challenge as
well also the other key thing in my
opinion with change management and
getting your standardization process or
your initiative for standardizing
point-of-care instrumentation to be
accepted would be identifying
stakeholders for every clinical area
that uses that task so having to be able
to pinpoint who's the main person in
this air can to make decisions for an
arrow who can who has influence over
others in that area it's a key thing it
it's it would be challenging to identify
who those people are and once you
identify them the next challenge would
be convincing them that standardizing is
the right thing to do and so we're gonna
see how we did some of that and so
knowing all these challenges that were
going to we were going to face we still
decided in my institution to undertake
standardization of our clinic
instrumentation for blood gas analysis
and a CT testing so today I'm not going
to discuss both of these I'm gonna use
our experience with standardizing blood
gas analysis as a case study to be able
to walk you through certain key steps
that came out of our experience in
standardizing kind of care testing with
the hopes that you'll be able to have
these as a basis to guide you on your
own standardization walk and so this is
kind of how our blood gas testing as was
set up in a hospital at the time when we
decided to undertake when a care
standardization for blood gas analysis
and you can see that we had four
different types of blood gas analyzer
Society mentioned earlier one hand
health which meant he could be taken
right there to the patient's bedside
and three benchtop analyzers which meant
that they were either on a car in
certain areas of the hospital or in the
blood gas lab we're testing the sample
would have to be taken to the
instrumentation for testing and then
results brought back to the provider and
so most of our critical care areas used
both had were using the bench tops we
would have respiratory therapists are
the ones that would perform testing on
the bench toxin that are critical or
intensive care units and for the other
parts of the hospital we would have
other personnel Oh perform blood gas
analysis and so the goal here is we have
four different types of analyzers for
what gas testing and we want to go down
to one and so where do we begin
basically and so there is this
interesting or really good quote that I
found on the American productivity and
quality Center blog from May 30th 2017
and it basically says what I'd said
before that for change management to
work the reason must be compelling and
so for us we realized that if you have
to start this we have to start by coming
up with this compelling reason as to why
all these different areas that are using
these different instrumentation have to
come to a consensus to use one type of
instrumentation and so the first thing
that we did was actually outline all the
issues that we identified as a result
all the issues that we had that were a
result of us having multiple different
types of instrumentation so we had I had
mentioned those earlier when I talked
about the challenges and so we went down
and actually down the listen listed out
every single issue that we identified in
different areas of the hospital so
certain areas of the hospital had more
issues or happy
pree analytic errors over more paranoid
errors than other areas of the hospital
but then other areas had more compliance
issues and so we went down to listen we
said all the issues that we identified
as a result as being a result of having
multiple different types of
instrumentation and the next thing that
we did was collecting the data finding
data to actually prove that yes these
were really an issue if we said that
okay you have a compliance issue with
maybe not running quality control or
maybe
because I had spent ties we're not
interface we had in some of the errors
they were actually printing out the
results and walking them to providers
and sometimes we would find those
results lying around so maybe
documenting those each time and
involving our compliance officer to
actually come and see what was going on
you know compiling enough data to be
able to prove that we say this is an
issue here's the data to to support that
if we said if we identified pre analytic
error we try to come up with data to
prove that costs was an area where as
you're gonna see I'm not really gonna
have data for costs today because it was
challenging for us to prove it but then
we were we could look for test volumes
the test volumes that we were currently
sending to or currently having on each
type of instrumentation and then we
looked at the total test volume and then
we would ask manufacturers to give us
put as to what would be our cost if this
was our volume and we compared that and
that's kind of what we used as our proof
to say okay this is gonna affect cost
and then we also use staff efficiency we
said you know we're gonna cut down the
steps from this many staffs to this many
steps in this would improve efficiency
we had a hard time finding hard numbers
because a lot of times with
point-of-care testing you have these
downstream benefits
sometimes you're not able to one
quantify as was the case for us and and
so the other thing that as I mentioned
earlier was we I learned at the hospital
compliance officer to let them know kind
of water the rest associated with the
status quo if we continue with all these
four different types of instruments and
the challenges that we had observed or
the issues that we identified what were
the rest to patient care patient safety
to the institution and and bringing in
the compliance officer really helped us
make a case or strengthen our case for
standardization so we could have better
buy-in with all of this data we now take
this we went ahead to identify different
stakeholders in different areas we
started by maybe trying to and then I
started from maybe the medical directors
for those areas if it was some intensive
care unit and sometimes you would go to
medical director and they would identify
somebody else to work with you or
something who could be their
representative or work with you for that
so that was kind of a starting point in
some areas we would start with maybe the
nursing manager and then we would slowly
find out who that a true stakeholder was
and sometimes we would go down the road
and then realize oh we had the wrong
person and then you have to come back so
we once we identified who the
stakeholder worse then we had this body
of data and the issues plaguing their
specific area to try to get their buy-in
to say yes it is important that we
standardize yes this is a problem and
yes standardizing would be advantageous
for us and so once we got buy-in from
all the different stakeholders for all
the areas that were utilizing or that
had need for blood gas analysis we then
went ahead to form a multidisciplinary
team so that's the first step for us
that we did so this
multi-disciplinary team did consist of
key decision-makers from all the
affected area so we had the stakeholders
identify individuals but then we also
reached out especially to the
administrative side of all the clinical
areas involved or affected and and have
them identify you know administrative
level individuals like nursing manager
surgery and coordinators but also
operators of the instrument type so we
wanted to make sure that we had
providers who are the people making the
decisions based on the results from
these internet types but then we also
had all the way down to those who were
the ones actually using the
instrumentation and applying the sample
to this instrument who had idea about
how user-friendly the instrument types
were and what they really needed in an
instrument and so having once we had the
small type person learning team and we
then task them with the goal of
identifying an instrument type that
would meet the needs the clinical needs
for all these different areas and and
make a recommendation as to the
instrument type and so we make sure that
their objectives we're very clear
because you don't want to just put out a
team and them not have direction as to
what they're supposed to do so we test
them with being able to take that's fine
an instrument type that would work for
all the different areas and so the first
thing that they did they had to do was
assess the situation and so they had to
go ahead and assess the different
clinical departments that were using
that that had blood gas analyzers and
also so been looking clinical needs but
then also the clinic care devices
themselves to see if these devices would
work for the different areas and so
what did we assess so I've list that
kind of like bullet points to the
different things that were on the list
and the different things that they
looked at in depth that the
multidisciplinary team looked at and I'm
not gonna be disgusting all of this
today in the interest of time but I will
be focusing in on some of these I would
certainly mention things about the
clinical needs for each area as we go
along but I'll discuss things like I'll
discuss workflow today you know because
that was one thing that was of interest
to us but also the compliance of quality
would be another thing that I've
discussed today and also another little
performance but certainly here you have
a list of the different things that the
multi are multi disciplinary committee
actually or a team actually went through
and looked at these different errors
with and assess them for each clinical
area basically to come up with an idea
as to what instrument type would be able
to meet the needs of all the different
areas of the hospital and so the first
thing that I would like to dove in-depth
into is that we assess would be the
workflow so I kind of mentioned briefly
earlier that for our bench top analyzers
we had so we had three different types
of bench top analyzers and in our
critical care areas or intensive care
units we have these blood gas analyzers
sitting in the blood gas nap per se so
it was more of a central location on
that floor or that intensive care unit
in that specific intensive care unit and
respiratory therapists are the ones that
perform testing on these bench tops no
other operators in the intensive care
unit a trained to use this but for our
respiratory therapists so what would
happen here who is that as
taps that would happen from the scene of
testing order to the results being
provided being given to the provider and
so you would have the nurse collect the
sample in some areas it was the
restoration phase correcting the sample
so if they're nice collecting the sample
then they'll pay sure is very therap is
to come collect the sample and then go
run the task but then they had several
different steps to running the tests
mainly because our instrument types were
not interfaces so you can see that there
are multiple steps in between where they
assign they still had to they would
enter in the the patient information the
reagent information assign an accession
number login to the Elias system to
assign this accession number and then
scan get a barcode scan it you know run
the task and then put in that
information to Li system so you can see
that there are so many tests so I've
condensed all those tests to just nine
steps on here as you can see in this
chart however if you actually looked at
all the sub test steps that they had to
go through there are about 23 to 27
steps so those goes without saying that
you could have multiple different errors
happen so the more steps you put in a in
a scenario in a situation the more room
for error you're providing and so and
the more variable the process for
example if they were in the NICU is a
different process in the pictures of
different process and so with all of
this variability there but you're just
giving room for error and so we did have
error happening because of that and so
you can see that with this workflow it
with have it would be a benefit to be
able to shrink this down and one big
thing that would benefit this process
would be interfacing the instrument but
because we have so many different
instrument types in the institution the
cost to interface every single time
benchtop analyzer was just too much and
so the institution couldn't do it
couldn't in interphase all these
different instrument tasks but because
we had made this Martha and a
standardization initiative we were able
to get buying from the institution if
you can give us one instrument type we
would be able to provide the resources
for it another thing that we did was tie
our standardization goal standardizing
our blood gas analyzers or to go to a
hospital goal so one of the the hospital
had this and started this initiative for
improving patient care delivery and one
of a part of that initiative was
bringing care closer to the patient's
bedside and so if we were able to
decrease the stats that were taking the
respiratory therapists away from the
patient's bedside for anywhere from ten
to forty minutes because of the sheer
numbers apps and if we could decrease
this and make make it such that the rest
Terry carapace to spend more time at the
patient's bedside doing what the rest or
therapist does make sure that ensuring
the welfare of the patient rather than
spending in a blood gas lab running a
test this certainly was was going to
improve patient care delivery and so by
tying back to the hospital goal we were
able to get more support and by it for
interfacing our instrument so we were
able to assess these workflows we had
people on the force observing the
different workflows in the different
areas and gathering information the
variability of the processes and as to
how where point of care would add value
in these tabs by definite leads
shrinking down the different steps to
just a few steps the other thing that we
assessed was the quality and one of the
things that we chose to assess quality
was the
eris and the specific Premila errors
that we chose to really gather data on
just because it was the instrument I
swear not interface it was just hard to
get a lot of data was current tech
reports so we just to take a look at the
different corrected reports that were
being done or for every single month so
we did this for every for the different
areas and so what I'm showing you our
current reports for one of our one of
the clinical areas in our Hospital and
so you can see that current reports were
around 14 or let's say I'm averaged
around 12:00 every per month and here
I'm showing you data for seven months
and when we looked drilled down to see
you know to see what the different
errors were and if what the specific
problems where we can you can see that
the biggest error the main reason for
the errors were having word is using the
ones and type so for example reporting a
result on and saying that it was
material sample for example rather than
meanwhile it was of Venus it was a blood
gas result under being a sample so that
was by far the biggest pre analytic
error that we found in this area and
across multiple areas but then they also
had issues with results being reported
on the wrong patient right and he had to
placate orders on the same patient and
incorrect results on an analyte so and
different and other error types that we
could not really identify but they would
do a corrected report so again because
our instruments were not really
interfaced and there was really no
electronic way for us to catch this B
suggest the the Karthi reports on the
error step we're caught so this lets us
know that there probably other errors
that were not caught so this is
certainly a patient safety issue that
you know again gave us a more compelling
reason
for standardizing and getting the the
instrumentation interface so that we
could prevent some of this error and so
what I'm showing you now the next thing
that we looked at where and that was
analytical performance so while the
multidisciplinary team was assessing all
these different areas the point-of-care
staff were performing and analytical
method comparisons between these four
different instrument types and our
laboratory instruments which were the
reference instrument for our institution
and so one thing that you can see from
this list here I'm showing you the menu
of tasks for bench tops in our handhelds
is the fact that bench tops are mention
ups did have a larger menu right they
were able to perform the biggest
difference with the handheld is the fact
that they perform call symmetry and so
you get measured hemoglobins which some
of our areas pointed out was the main
test clinical need that they had they
needed a measured no globin they capture
a human will not work for them because
they had more he will do that patients
which would interfere with conductivity
which is the main method that's used for
that would provide calculate a
hemoglobin result and our handhelds had
fewer tasks so it would be more
advantageous if you could just go with
the bench tops so we did prove do
analytical performance method
comparisons between these instrument
types and our point of care instrument
and the lab and on but today I'm only
gonna discuss the comparison the results
from three different analytes
highlighted here in red sodium potassium
and hemoglobin mainly because these were
the some of the analyzed that the
analyzed that some of the areas
talked about has been very important for
them and the analyzed that we were
closely looking at for our blood gases
and the different analytes we didn't
really see a significant difference we
had we showed really good comparison
with glass and so
with a little method comparison of
sodium to the laboratory method what you
can see from this Deming regression plot
showing our blood gas analyzers of
poincare instrumentation on the y axis
and our lab instrumentation on the x
axis is the fact that you can see that
benchtop 2 is showing the negative bias
to the lab you can see the equivalent
the line of equivalencies of the dotted
line which is in black and the benchtop
2 is showing the negative bias meanwhile
the other different instrument types we
shouldn't positive by so just looking at
this you can see that there was a
variability in performance when it came
to sodium is so looking at this data a
different way by looking at the blend
Outman plots which is a bias blood so
this shows us the bias a little bit more
closely the bias that these blood gas
analyzers had to laughs you can see that
our bench top one had showed the
positive bias and the mean bias is
around three point three so the total
allowable error for sodium is four so
for us even though that's within the
allowable error we were like huh that's
that's kind of high you know especially
if you look at that spread you can see
that there were several analytes there
that we're outside the 200 certain the
several points that are outside the door
allow the error vector to is the one-man
show the it actually shows the mean bias
there's more quote as it's not as large
and a bench subtree also has good
performance and our handheld did show a
positive bias as well but again it's so
within the total allowable error so just
looking at these sodium results it does
look based on this bench top two and
three showed the best performance for
each sodium if you're looking at
potassium here this Demming regression
plot you can see that
actually shows really good performance
right so you the results are all there's
really good comparison with lab and if
you look at the biased plots it's the
same so potassium is one area that they
were a little bit concerned about
because of pre analytic errors but you
can see that we did have really good
comparison to lab and so potassium
wasn't a worry for us so looking at
hemoglobin you can looking at the
performance of hemoglobin you can see
that two instruments bench top three and
the handheld negative bias to layout
meanwhile vegetable one and to show the
equivalent or slightly positive bias to
lab and so one thing that I want to
point out which I omit at to point out
in beginning is the population of
patients that we use for this study we
use whole blood samples left over whole
blood specimens from patients that were
undergoing cardiovascular surgery so
this is a population of patients that
would most likely be hemo diluted as I
said before for methods that use
conductivity if a sample of patients he
will doing that or bleeding heavily this
would give falsely negative results with
conductivity conductivity actually
point-of-care instrumentation that used
to knock Timothy to give you a
calculated haemoglobin results usually
would measure the hematocrit by
conductivity and then calculate
hemoglobin result and so if a picture
was he module that you would generally
have falsely negative leap bias results
compared to what they really are and so
looking at these results here you can
tell that those methods the instrument
types that use spectral
spectrophotometry to measure hemoglobin
to give you measured result did show
good performance or comparable
performance to the laboratory instrument
meanwhile the two methods that
instrumentation that were using
conductivity did show the negative bias
so this does this is kind of what we
expected to see if you were using
patient samples that patients that were
hemo diluted and so you can tell already
that we would not be able to use
benchtop 3 that bias is too large
outside the total allowable error for
for a hemoglobin and bench and we would
not be able to use that for in this
population of patient even our handheld
should even though it's within the Torah
a well where our provider said no this
is this is still not acceptable right
it's not acceptable performance so again
we would not use this just goes to show
that we would not use this instrument
type in this population of patients and
so however because we were interested in
the handheld because of the value that
it could add in being able to allow our
raspberry terrapass or our operators to
be right there at the patient's bedside
providing results in real time right
there and not taking them away from the
bedside we wanted to take a look to see
you know are we are we gonna see the
same thing in just routine samples
hopefully samples that we sent to the
lab for routine testing samples that are
coming from all the other floors of the
hospital and not from cardiovascular
surgery so these are samples that were
not likely to be hemo diluted and so
when we did do that comparison to laughs
we saw a similar performance to those
instrument types that has
spectrophotometry so we see that
slightly positive bias and so we did not
see that negative bias that we observed
with the he module that samples so this
did tell us that yes we could use this
instrument in a population of patients
that are not chemo diluted which would
be in other areas of the hospital and so
just looking at them a little
performance data their recommendation
based on that performance data would be
benched up to because it didn't have
sodium issues a high positive bias as we
saw with bench top one it didn't have
issues with conductivity and so bench
top two would be the instrument type
that was recommended based on analytical
performance the handheld would be could
be used because it did show good
performance sodium and potassium but
then it showed good performance with
hemoglobin in certain populations of
patient and not in others so you would
not be able to use an institution-wide
but in certain areas and so aren't with
all of the assessment data the next step
would be now look at all of this data
including analytical performance
clinical needs easy ease of use of
instrumentation so we wanted part of the
assessment was having a clinical area
give pros and cons of their instrument
type why they would want to keep it or
why they wouldn't want to keep it so all
of this information was used to come up
with the recommendation was just write a
multidisciplinary team to come up with a
recommendation and so if you remember
the goal was to standardize to one
instrument type however because of the
hospital's goal to keep care to bring
care closer to the patient's bedside to
improve care delivery we did the
multidisciplinary team recommended using
handheld in the areas of the hospital
that didn't have interference with
hemoglobin or and use the bench top in
those areas that did need measured
hemoglobins for example in our
cardiovascular surgery area so these
were the concentration when I have you
here the constitution's that went in
deciding to use both the handheld and
standardized two one hand held in one
bench top rather than just to a single
bench top which would give us all the
test that we would want or need and so
and so these were the considerations
that went into making this decision and
after making this decision we didn't
just want to implement it we decided to
take the pilot we took a piloted
approach we piloted just using a
handheld in a certain area of the
hospital that did not require mention
did not really want measured hemoglobin
or did not really need measured
hemoglobin and only use a bench top if
cosmetic was needed and so for the
purposes of the pilot we did take away
the bench tops from that floor so we did
the pilot in the PICU the reason why we
Chesapeake is because they were then
with the area that were most accepting
of the change so you do not want to go
in and pilot in that area that does not
want change so an area that is more
accepting of the changes would be the
best era for the pilot and so this the
pilot needed that we educate providers
because they were going from always
having co-op symmetry with every sample
that was tested and to a situation where
they were not going to have cost much a
unless they they ordered awesome entry
and so a lot of training weddings for
the providers our residents our nurses
basically everyone for the operators
there's a lot of training and then we
implemented this and we went ahead for
the pilot for five months during this
pilot we did collect quite a bit of data
we wanted to see you know how often do
they really need coops and one thing we
found was before they were always
getting cost during this time when they
did have coops on the floor really
throughout the five months nobody
ordered costs for this area and so and
here I'm showing you data from the other
areas and you can see that the area like
a cardiac intensive care unit that
didn't need co-op summation because they
had so they have patients who are on
nitric oxide treatment and that causes
methemoglobinemia so they need that core
symmetry for the management of these
patients you can see that those hairs do
get co-op symmetry testing meanwhile the
area that doesn't really need it now
we've done work test utilization where
they're not really getting that task
when they don't need it and so now they
would do they still have that test
available to them if they need it but it
just has to be run on a different floor
and so based on this we on the outcomes
of our pilots we it confirmed that for
certain areas they probably do not need
a bench top to be on that floor so that
men there are fewer areas where we would
need to put in the best shops for
example in our cardiovascular surgery or
our and so on here again I just put a
quick list of the different things
information that we collected from the
pilot we took a look again and workflow
did we make any improvements did we add
value to care how many instruments are
needed so that this will give us an idea
to more white implementation
implementing invest throughout the
hospital so after providing the
recommendation and piloting us in one
area and having the information that we
need to be able to four different areas
we went ahead to implement this in the
hospital so institution-wide so we
didn't do to implementation all at once
we still decided to do an area by area
so that we could have time to focus on
the single area work out all the Kings
before moving on so during the pilot we
initially wanted to do it for three
months but they extended to five months
because we were able to identify issues
which were able to fix and work out and
before moving on to implementing it in
other areas and every area we realized
was unique and so we were able to do
that and so we in the interest of time
I'm gonna go through the last few slides
and so you can see that implementing the
main thing would be training you have to
train several different operators in
this case we had hundreds of operators
we had
tens of providers to train and then you
have to set a goal life date and make
sure everyone understands exactly what's
gonna happen on that goal life date and
how that's gonna happen and what the new
form flows would be and so what did we
gain from standardizing it goes without
saying we can't staff efficiency and so
far we've been able to get improved not
just personal satisfaction but also
provider satisfaction right we were able
to cut down our our pre standardization
testing times which would go anywhere
from 10 to 40 minutes to under five
minutes it didn't matter if they were
using a bench top or not the main reason
for this improvement was because of our
bench tops becoming standardized and we
even got a provider telling me one day
like this is point-of-care at its best
because they were so happy with the
improvement or the value that
point-of-care added to their to the
patient care and another thing that we
gained was improve quality and so you
can see as we discussed earlier a pre
standardization corrected report in that
one specific area that I shared with you
and you can see post immunization
sometimes we would get two maybe three
according to the reports but that's
mainly because of the that those who are
all because of sample types so sometimes
they would say they want a Tyrael
samples and then they would change their
minds to what testing but then forget to
switch the sample type and so that was
mainly the type of error but with
education now that air is almost
non-existent cost savings we were able
to show that yes we did save cost again
I don't have hard numbers for you but
they were able to realize that oh we no
longer have four different maintenance
fees but now we just have to maintain as
fees and so again and also because of
the increased volumes who are able to
get decreased of cost for our supplies
from our vendors and so knowing these
advanced
and kind of what you could gain or would
you be outward Oh taking the challenge
and actually going through
standardization again going back to the
ACC and 2018 when I asked this question
most of the people everyone basically a
hundred percent said yes we do want to
standardize because there are so many
advantages so just to summarize again to
go through standardization I think that
the most important part is certainly
provided of doing the groundwork getting
that compelling data that you need of
comparing information that you need to
be able to convince your incision that
change is needed because this is more
like a foundation if you do do really
good Brown work then you wanted oh that
would be most of the challenges that you
would have to overcome with especially
when it comes to change management and
so next thing would be forming a
multidisciplinary team assessing the
situation
providing your recommendation and we do
recommend piloting it in an area that is
very acceptable of the change and then
going ahead with your implementation and
not forgetting to put in place processes
that would allow for you as the point of
care Department you monitor and maintain
compliance and quality of this testing
so you can actually see this this flow
that I have on here it published in the
clinical lab news by a ACC in bench
matters section and also I have those
links at the bottom here and also as
scientific Schwartz by the ACC Academy
so you can certainly see these texts and
more details as to what I experienced
worse in those two publications so with
that I would take any I would say thank
you for listening and I would take any
questions that you might have thank you
thank you dr. Sewell alone for that
informative presentation
we will now start the Q&A portion of the
webinar and we'll address some of the
most commonly asked questions by our
viewers if you have any questions like
to ask please do so now just click on
the ask a question drop-down box located
on the far left to your presentation
window type your question into the box
that appears on your screen and click
the send button our speaker will follow
up with your questions via email so
let's get started our first question is
how did you decide on what for blood gas
instruments to evaluate when there are
so many on the market for us that was a
that was a no-brainer mainly because as
I said before we started out with four
different types of instrument for
instrument types with point-of-care
testing because we had those four
instrument Tison and looking at the
publication's or in discussing with
colleagues from other institutions it
turns out that those instrument types
were also the most commonly used
instrument types for blood gas analysis
in most institutions and also there were
several publications showing that these
instrument types had good performance
and in meeting clinical needs in
different areas so with that we decided
to evaluate just those instrument types
that we had which were for and not go
out and look for a new instrument tax
even though there are newer instrument
types on the market and we did have
people are approaching us so we decided
to start with what we have and I would
advise for areas to start what they have
unless they are not satisfied with what
any of the things they have in-house and
they want to look for something new or
something outside or a new and improved
then that's when I would say okay go
ahead and look at something else but we
started with what we have what we have
and it looks like and it looks like we
have time for one more question in your
view what was the critical factor in
your successful standardization of
point-of-care testing instrumentation
in my field I would say it would be
identifying stakeholders because that
was I didn't show it in my talk but that
was the I would say as we say in
chemistry rate limiting step for us that
was like the bottle make that was the
part that delayed us the most having
been able to identify who's the main
who's the key person in that clinical
area that we needed to talk to because
several times we would do so much work
and we would go to the drawing board
just to realize that oh we have the
wrong person and then we would have to
come back and then start from scratch
get that person convinced and then get
their buy-in before we start all over
and they're like well this is really our
need in this area it's not this it's
this this is what we want to do this
what we are one accomplish and so in my
view I would say identifying the
stakeholders early on is key you know
and would make an already challenging
situation go a lot smoother I would like
to once again thank dr. Seal Island for
her presentation I would also like to
thank laboratory King today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through February of
2019
you will receive an email from lab roots
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for real life and I'll
smooth with your colleagues who may have
missed today's event that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon goodbye